It's being described as Spain's most divisive
general election in decades.
Voters head to the polls again today - for
the third time in four years.
The party of Socialist Prime Minister Pedro
Sanchez is expected to get the most votes
-- but may not garner enough support to form
a government.
That means he'll need the backing of smaller
parties, which are enjoying a surge in support.
Many voters are still weighing their options.
There's still plenty of indecision on the
streets of Madrid.
Polls show about four in ten Spaniards don't
know who to vote for on Sunday.
For many, it's no longer simply a choice between
the two traditional parties - the center-left
Spanish Socialist Workers' Party, or the center-right
People's Party.
"I am going to vote for the left wing party
Unidas Podemos, because the traditional parties
have deceived us too often.
They were involved in so many corruption scandals
and have never delivered on their promises."
"I think it's great that there are now more
than only two alternatives.
I couldn't identify with any of the traditional
parties but there weren't any other real options."
The far-right Vox party looks set to win seats
in the national parliament for the first time.
It's predicted to win at least ten percent
of the vote with its populist, anti-immigrant
and anti-feminist message - a sentiment that
resonates with many.
"I like how they defend Spain and our civil
liberties, they want to cut taxes and put
an end to the gender ideology that promotes
abortion and criminalizes men.
We young people are sick of our traditional
politicians, doing the opposite of what they
promise."
40 years after the end of General Franco's
dictatorship, Spain finds itself with a resurgent
far-right - just like many of its European
neighbors.
"Spain’s traditional
parties will no longer be able to form a
government on their own.
So it’s the small parties that will determine
who will run this country for the coming four
years."